waiting to aim thus with françois
basket my parents at the sea
that I don't put that I have it well our
church its old porch by which
we laugh about it black bold the commons and black
were oblique and deeply dug
at the angles as well as  the stoup where he
led us as if the doubs is
clearly insanity of the peasants of the
peasants entering the church is of
our right shy first name of the
holy water could repeat for
centuries acquire a destructive force
there you periods in the band
against  which she wants that every
day these tombstones on which
the noble dust of isabey rubble and
buried the vigil in the heart like a
spiritual paving were no longer able
to inert and hard matter because the
time of opinions made soft and made
flow like honey out of the limits of
their package and carys on which if it
had exceeded a white flank between
drifting a
gothic capital honfleur noyon  of the
white violence of the marble and below which
elsewhere it had been reabsorbed
still contracts the elliptical Latin inscriptions
introducing one more whim in the
arrangement of these abbreviated characters
bringing together letters of a word in the
others had been disproportionately
stretched these stained glass windows  the shimmer
never evident that the day the
sun sells very few are only made
hybrid hours was sure that it would be
fine in the
church one was filled in all its
grandeur by a single character similar to
the place of  deck of cards who lived
there at the architectural sub-index between
heaven and earth and in our ranks
blick scourge in peace blues of which sometimes
on weekdays at noon when
there are no sons in one of its rare
times when l  The church is vacant more
or more human luxurious with
sunshine this rich sense of furniture
looked almost habitable like the
carved stone ax and glass bath of a
medieval style hotel in  to see her
young laden ones clouded for a moment
Madame will act placing on the
neighboring kneeler a package all tied up with petit
fours that she has that she has just
taken from the pastry chef opposite and that
she was going to bring back for lunch
in  another a mountain of
red snow at the foot of which a
fight was taking place seemed to have frozen on the very
glass roof that it must blow 200
troubles crisis not like a pane on
which the series remain waves
when but waves when lit by a
few roms  by that very no doubt that
they in skin taken from the hotel table
inside so fresh that seemed rather to
pose in momentarily by a gleam
from outside ready to vanish than to speak
of the colors attached forever alain
pierre and all were six former
qu  'send hall to silver room is
one and from the dust of centuries
and show nothing threadbare
the weft of their soft tapestry of
glass there was one which was a
compartment divided into a u  some of the
rectangular stained glass windows or dominated the blue
like a large deck of cards similar to
what must have been distracting right chang
May 6 is that a ray of the evening brier that
my moujan gaze took him
through the glass roof will have to turn is one
of the values  but at the shifting and precious
fire the next moment she had
taken on the changing brilliance of a drag of
bread then she trembles and wanders and
parks her flaming is fantastic
which disgusts is of the cindered otter
rocky the name of the damp walls
like  if it was in the nave of some
Elysian caves the winding
victims that I followed my parents who
carried their parishioners a moment
after the summer vitro en rhombus had taken
the deep transparency in france bible
hardness sapphire which would have it was just
posed  on some immense pectoral but
behind which in health most loved and
all the riches a smile a
smile rising from the sun he was
also recognizable in the waves b  leus
and soft including a donut the feet ferry
that on the pavement of the square where the straw
of the market and even on our first
Sunday that we had arrived at ben
table it consoled me that the earth was
still bare and black and making it bloom
like a  historical spring and which
dated from the successors of saint
louis hides dazzling fields of
forget-me-nots towards two
high-warp tapestries represent the coronation
of estaires tradition wanted that
it be given and to suez us the features of a
king of france and  to esther those of a
lady of war members of whom they were
friends
ok their colors founding life
added an expression in phonic relief
the rage a little pink floating on the
lips of estaires beyond the drawings of
their outlines of people of  her dress
this year presently six so
handsomely that they entail a sort
of consistency and without lifting briskly
on the pent-up atmosphere and the greenery
of the arms remained lively in the
lower parts of the pann  water of silk and wool
but having passed through the top drill to stand
out paler above the
sides of the 30 French the high branches
yellowing golden and like a half
erased erased by the abrupt and
oblique illuminations of an
invisible sun all this and  even more the
precious objects came to the church of
characters who were for me almost
legendary characters the golden cross
work and ponds by sat is law
and year by dagobert the tomb of the sons
of germanic usury  in porphyry
and enameled copper because of which I
advanced into the church
when the gaining our chairs as in
a valley to visit facts or the
peasant marvel to see in a
rock in a tree in a pond the
palpable traces  of their passage over
natural all that made her for
me something entirely
different from the rest the city
a building occupying if one can say
a space with four dimensions the
fourth being that of time
past  plowing through the 120 centuries
what of shackled labor to escape
the purchase
seemed to overcome and overcome
not just a few yards but
successive wrecks
from which he emerged victorious from the robes
remove the fierce 11th century in
the smugglers of his  walls
dwayne in paris it is with that of the
saints butcher is blind and
large and white which by the deep
notch which dug near the porch
the staircase of the bell tower and even
concealed it by the graceful 1.4 gotti
which pressed  coquettishly in front of him
like a bigger sister to
hide him from strangers stands
smiling in front of a young boorish brother
winner is badly dressed and raising in the
sky above the square his tower which
had contemplated saint louis and seemed
to see him again and again  sinking with its
crypt into a Merovingian night where
it guides us while waiting for it to move
dark and powerfully nenê bure and like
the same bram bran of an immense
stone bat theo  dore and his
sister light us with a candle the
tomb of the granddaughter of the supers is
revealed to be a deep valve like the
trace of a fossil had been dug
17 years by a crystal lamp which on the
evening of the master of princess franck
s  'was detached by itself from the chains
of a where it hung in the place
of the current apse and without the
crystal breaking without the flame
it is annie had sunk into the
stone and you l  did you hurt me to
give it away under z
the apse of the church of congress can we
really talk about it
she was so crude on clouds of
artistic beauty same
religious impetus from outside like
the crossroads on which she
overlooked was  below, its crude
mirail rises from a basement
leading in no way polished bristling with
pebbles and which had nothing
particularly ecclesiastical the
windows seemed to be pierced at an
excessive height everything looked more
like a prison wall  that many churches and
serve  later when i remembered
all the glorious apses that i have seen
it would never have occurred to me to
bring the apse of cambrai closer to it
only one day at the bend of a small
street provencia provincial i saw
opposite the intersection of three most beautiful
a rough and raised wall with the
last ring openings and offering the
same asymmetrical appearance as the apse the
congress so I asked myself I did
not ask myself like a castle or in reims
with what power there  the
religious feeling was expressed but I
voluntarily exclaimed the church
the family church adjoining rue
saint-hilaire
or was it bringing a horde of its
two neighbors
the wife as well as monsieur rappaz and the
house of madame l'oiseau that  she touches
and without any separation simple
citizen of cambrai who could have had
her number in the street if the view of
cambrai had had numbers and where it
seems that the postman wants to stop in
the morning when he f  easy its
distribution
before entering madame loiseau and on
leaving monsieur rapin there
was nevertheless between them and everything that
he was not a demarcation
like my mind naj
my feet stopped crossing
madame loiseau had  beautiful to have fuchsias at her
window which had the bad
habit of letting their branches
always run everywhere headlong and
whose flowers had nothing more in a
hurry when she was old enough than
to go and refresh their tecan purple cheeks
manager against the ashes
facade of the church the fuchsias do
not deviate sacred do not become sacred for this
for me between the flowers and the
blackened stone on which would be that which
it leaned on if my eyes did
not perceive an interval my mind
reserve an abyss